ja ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir es mit martin heidegger zu
tun bekommen werden
bevor wir uns heiliger zuwenden müssen
wir noch ein bisschen rückblicken auf
die letzte sitzung
da hatten wir auch einen ganz
interessanten philosophen eine gute
zusammenfassung richtig geben und
nämlich diesen herren hier alexius
meinung und ich kann so viel sagen er
ist ein philosoph des späten neunzehnten
jahrhunderts frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts kam aus österreich als es
dem damaligen österreich und hat sich
wie andere denker der phänomenologie
also etwa puzzle ist ein ganz verwandter
denke sehr mit begriffen befasst die
unsere gegenstands beziehung betreffen
das stichwort ist hier internationalität
dass es der das zentrum also es geht
darum wie der geist der menschliche
geist gerichtet ist auf verschiedene
gegenstände und jetzt möchte ich ihnen
hier eine kurze zusammenfassung geben
aus vor allem aus seiner schrift über
die stellung der gegenstand theorie im
system der wissenschaften von 1907
system der wissenschaften und
gegenstands theorie das sind die
stichwörter gegenstands theorie bedeutet
es ist die theorie vom gegenstand also
jetzt endlich von den gegenständen
unseres geistes das kann gegenstand sein
der empfindung also ein gefühlter
gegenstand ein gefühltes objekt das kann
und gedachte gegenstand zahlen das kann
ein urteil seien also alle akte die sich
auf etwas richten sind damit bezeichnet
zusammen ein paar leitfragen gehabt was
versteht meinung unter gegenstands
theorie weitere frage ist was versteht
man unter einem objektiv gegenüber
objekt was versteht meinung unter
unmöglichen gegenständen das ist das
hauptthema der sitzung welchen unter
logischen status haben nach meinung
unmögliche gegenstände war die wie genau
existiert wenn überhaupt ein rundes
viereck also ein rundes 4 ist so ein
kandidat für einen unmöglichen
gegenstand
inwiefern ist meinungs- theorie
problematisch und zum schluss nie
verhält sich meinungs- theorie und
theologie zu den bisherigen theorie wir
werden sehen der kurzen zusammenfassung
die jetzt gäbe dass ich meinung auf kant
bezieht und zwar auf dieses zitat wo er
sagt 100 gedachte thaler und 100
wirklich existiere thaler sind vom
gehalte genau identisch also 100 reale
tyler sind näher taler als 100 gedachte
thaler
also erstens und existenz sind jetzt
nicht bekannt so verbunden dass die
existenz die essenz verändert und wir
wollen jetzt schauen wie meinung sind
dazu verhält meine these ist und die
gilt jetzt für das gesamte seminar die
lautet folgendermaßen wie sich die frage
der moral der freiheit des menschen
besonders in ihrem rand und
schattenbereich zum beispiel den bösen
entscheidet so entscheidet sich die
frage nach der theologie an der frage
nach möglichen gegenständen wie etwa
einen runden vier ich also meine these
ist die die philosophie kommt dann
besonders zu interessanten ergebnissen
werden sie sich mit randbereichen
beschäftigt die eigentlich aus dem
rahmen fallen bei platon hatten wir
gesehen dass es dort
diese sie haben sie erinnern sich noch
bei platon dieses linien gleichnis nach
oben rechts wieder hat ein youtube video
und linke eine plattform gab es ein
spektrum ganz unten unter den schatten
war eigentlich das nichts angesiedelt
und blasen hat darüber nicht viel gesagt
und da wird dann aber gerade spannend
kann es nach platten die idee des runden
4x geben das ist die spannende frage
platt und hätte sicherlich gesagt das
ist keine idee das ist überhaupt keine
idee jetzt würde aber meinungen dagegen
sagen wir können aber sehr wohl die idee
denken dass es ein rundes vier gibt also
wir können den begriff rundes viereck
bilden auch wenn es ein
widersprüchlicher begriff ist aber wir
können es zu einem begriff erheben und
hier hätte jetzt platt an probleme
bekommen
und das ist also immer das spannende
auch in der moral auch in der freiheits
debatte immer zu schauen was sind die
randbereiche gilt die theorie auch noch
die dahin philosoph eine philosophin
aufstellt wenn wir die randbereiche
betreffen zb das böse was häufig
übergehen übergangen wird weil es so
unerfreulich ist aber ich glaube wir
haben hier eine parallele auch in der
anthologie bei fragen nach möglichen
gegenständen
so jetzt ist ja wie ich schon sagte der
zentrale begriff ist der begriff der
internationalität
das bedeutet nach dem zitat von meinung
dass ich jetzt vorlese dass man nicht
erkennen kann ohne etwas zu erkennen
allgemeiner dass man nicht urteilen ja
auch nicht vorstellen kann ohne über
etwas zu urteilen etwas vorzustellen
gehört zum selbstverständlichsten dass
bereits eine ganz elementare betrachtung
dieser ergibt erlebnisse gibt ergibt und
weiter sagte niemand verkennt dass dem
psychischen geschehen dieses
eigentümlich auf etwas gerichtet sein so
außerordentlich häufig zu kommt dass es
mindestens sehr nahe liegt nahe gelegt
ist darin ein charakteristisches moment
des psychischen gegenüber nicht
psychischen zu vermuten
all dieses gerichtet sein das ist die
intention ali tät und die zeichen dass
psychische und das geistige grübel
gegenüber nicht psychischen aus wie zb
gegenüber bloßer materie die nicht
beliebt ist
er sagt noch was dazu der psychische
vorgang gehen wir als erkennbar nennen
macht genau genommen für sich allein den
erkenntnis tatbestand noch nicht aus
erkenntnis ist sozusagen eine doppelt
tatsache in der dem erkennen dass er
kannte also ein relativ selbständiges
gegenübersteht auf das jenes nicht nur
etwa in der weise falsche urteile
gerichtet ist dass sie mehr durch den
psychischen akt gleichsam ergriffen
erfasst wird oder wie man sonst in
unvermeidlich bildlicher weise zu
beschreiben versuchen mag was
unbeschreiblich ist und jetzt haben wir
hier so dieses schema
also wir haben den erkenntnis akt das
kann also sein erkennen beurteilen auch
fühlen auch fühlen ist eine form von
erkenntnis wenn man es weit fasst
das ist alle die aktivität die beim
erkennen stattfindet zb die anstrengung
des dass sich ausrichten und haben wir
den gegenstand der erkenntnis die
internationalität das heißt wir haben
erkennen und erkanntes sind abhängig
voneinander
das sind ist eine relation eine
korrelation und wir können das eine
nicht ohne das andere haben die menschen
die unterschiedlichen menschen werden
unterschiedliche erkenntnis akte
vollziehen
der gegenstand ist sind auch immer
derselbe das sollte dann auch für edmund
husserl und anderen philosophen sehr
sehr zentral werden
er nennt es dann noch immer ist der
erkenntnis gegenstand um die neue sis
ist der erkenntnis akt also diese
unterscheidung zwischen erkennen prozess
und erkenntnis gegenstand ist ganz
zentral für diese zeit so jetzt sagt er
noch was das also es allen psychischen
wesentlich ist ein gegenstand zu haben
das ist das entscheidende für ihn und
jetzt gibt es noch interessantes thema
ich habe es mal die existenz der
nichtexistenz genannt ist ein bisschen
paradox formuliert aber das trifft
meines erachtens genau diese einsicht
von meinung auch nicht existierendes
existiert irgendwie ja also auch
widersprüchliches paradoxes können wir
bedenken
wir können darüber sprechen und deswegen
muss es auch irgendwie existieren und
ich glaube dass das sehr gut durch die
formel die existenz der nichtexistenz
gefasst wird und wir müssen hier einfach
zwischen verschiedenen formen der
existenz unterscheiden meinung macht es
dann so dass er von da sein spricht also
die reale existenz zb der gegenstand die
nicht anfassen kann und die existenz im
sinne des gegenständlich werden alles
gegenstand meines denkens erkennens
unter walter sein und auch das muss eine
gewisse existenz haben denn sonst könnte
ich ja gar nicht dran denken als auch
ein rotes quadrat ein rundes viereck
muss irgendwie existieren weil ich sie
zum begriff machen kann wenn es nichts
wäre könnte ich es auch nicht
thematisieren
das ist so die grund 1
und die finde ich sehr spannend und
jetzt sagte eben sehr überzeugend ich
finde er sagt es ist im grunde eine sehr
einfach erwägung aus der dies abzunehmen
ist nichts ist gewöhnlich als etwas
vorzustellen oder über etwas zu urteilen
was nicht existiert
es kann mit dieser nichtexistenz
ziemlich verschieden gewarnt sein
dieselbe kann auf einen widerstreit
zurückgehen wie beim unten 4x ich kann
eine bloß tatsächlich ist sein wie bei
einem schuldenberg
es kann sich um etwas handelt das seiner
natur nach insofern nicht eigentlich
existieren kann als es gar nichts reales
ist zb die gleichheit zwischen 3 und 3
die verschiedenheit zwischen rot und
grün kann schon dem sprachgebrauch nach
bestehen aber nicht in der weise
existieren wie etwa ein haus oder ein
baum
endlich kann etwas zwar real seien
überdies existiert haben oder in zukunft
existieren nicht aber in der gegenwart
gleichwohl wird das gegenwärtig
vorgestellt die vorstellung existiert
also wer aber wird aus etwas bereits
einer theoretischen vorwarnung zu liebe
annehmen wollen dass zwar die
vorstellung existiere
der inhalt aber nicht also meinung
unterscheidet jetzt ganz verschiedene
formen von nichtexistenz also wir haben
jetzt die existenz nichtexistenz
aufgrund eines wieder streites das wäre
ein rundes viereck also das prädikat
rund verträgt sich nicht mit dem
prädikat vier etwas im subjekt zu
enthalten ist oder es kann etwas sein
wie ein goldener berg der existiert
natürlich real nicht aber er könnte
existieren
dank so war es ganz abstrakt dass wir
die gleichheit zwischen 3 und 3 die
existiert natürlich auch es ist der fall
das 3 und 3 gleich sind aber wie soll
die gleichheit zwischen 3 und 3
existieren ganz seltsam und natürlich
existieren baum und haus ganz physisch
real also hier gibt es eine ganze
vielfalt von nicht existenzen und das
bringt meinung in die nähe einer
phänomenologie die phänomenologie ist
eine philosophische disziplin die die
phänomene also die erscheinungen die
gegenstände auch unseres bewusstseins
möglichst weiter differenziert und hier
sehen wir dass im fall der nicht access
die meisten menschen würden sagen
nichtexistenz darüber brauchen wir gar
nicht weiter reden das existiert ja
nicht aber es ist ein bisschen
komplizierter jetzt gab es etwas kritik
an meinung die er selbst aufnimmt als
ein rundes 4 welches ist welche nähere
nicht nur nichts und es wäre mit verlaub
gesagt als etwas was kein gegenstand ist
zu bezeichnen weiterer einwand den
eigentlichen nachdruck liegt bird wasser
das war sein kritiker darauf dass durch
anerkennung solcher unmöglich dagegen
stellt der satz des widerspruches seine
unumschränkte geltung verlöre
natürlich kann ich diese konsequenz in
keiner weise ausweichen
wer sich einmal auf ein rundes viereck
einlässt wird einem vier- oder sonst
einem objekte gegenüber das zugleich
rund und nicht und ist zurückhaltender
sein dürfen also die kritik von bertrand
russell diesen bekannten englischen
philosophen gesagt wenn wir so was wie
ein rundes vier als existierend annehmen
dann behaupten wir dass der widerspruch
existiert also wir bejahen ein
widerspruch wir sagen der widerspruch
ist richtig und das quadrat ist
widerspruch ist korrekt wir würden also
und selbst widersprechen wir würden die
logik vernichten und dieser diesen
eigentlich sehr scharfsinnige einmal
versucht jetzt meinung zu entgehen
die man sagt dadurch dass wir nicht
existierende gegenstand oder unmögliche
gegenstände annehmen
so muss man es genauer sagen begehen wir
keinen widerspruch in der logik es geht
verträgt sich mit unserer logik hier
kommt jetzt in diesem zitat noch seine
kritik an kant zum ausdruck er sagt hier
am ende es ist in der tat kaum ganz
genau von kants wirklich 100 talern zu
behaupten sie hätten vor den 100
gedachten talern gegenständlich gar
nichts heraus das heißt nicht dass den
letzteren fehlt also bei meinung wird
jetzt existenz wieder zu einem art
prädikat wir können verschiedener
hinsicht über existenz sprechen
wir können über 100 gedachte thaler
sprechen inso
wenn sie existieren weil sie ein
gegenstand meines denkens sind und
gedachte teile insofern existieren sie
als möglicher gegenstand aber immer noch
als gegenstand und wir können über 100
thaler so reden dass sie wirklich
existieren dass ich sie in der hand habe
er sich zum beispiel auch mit ihnen
kausal was tun kann die 100 wirkliche
teilhabe eine kausale kraft die 100
mögliche thaler nicht haben oder 100 nur
gedacht habe das heißt meinung
unterscheidet hier noch strenger als es
kann tut zwischenformen der existenz
genau er nimmt das auch existenziell
bestimmungen die unsere existenz
betreffen die die existenz begriffen
gegenüber kante zwischen 100 gedachten
100 wirklich in thailand keine
existenziellen unterschied gesehen hatte
dafür in existenz kein prädikat ist
unterscheidet meinung den existenz
begriff weiter er spricht da wie gesagt
von existenziell bestimmungen und man
muss davon auch das dasein unterscheiden
also existierend sein ist für mein und
erstmal nur die gegenstands fähigkeit
überhaupt also dass etwas gegenstand
meiner erkenntnis oder meines denkens
zahlen kann das kann eben auch ein
rundes quadrat und hier unterscheidet er
sich eben von kampf und bringt ein
beispiel zum beispiel die zahl null wie
ist es damit nah die zahl null
bezeichnet eigentlich nichts ist nichts
aber dennoch kooperieren die
mathematiker mit der zahl 0
und das ist ein gutes beispiel für den
fall der im nicht ex oder unmöglichen
gegenstände dass wir eben auch sie als
irgendwie existierend ansehen müssen